. There is a very notable double standard
that is taking place, as we predicted, between
the Donald Trump sexual assault allegations
and what's going on with Andrew Cuomo.
Now, I want to remind everybody I don't care
about political party.
When it was Anthony Weiner, I said, look at
what this guy this guy is accused of terrible
things.
I have nothing to say in defense of him.
It's a shame in that he had some good political
ideas.
But how am I going to defend this guy with
Al Franken?
I thought the resignation happened too soon.
In retrospect, that definitely happened too
soon and it happened too soon, in part because
Democrats too quickly started saying he should
resign.
What you know what, Al Franken, the crass
joke Al Franken was involved in was not good.
But compared to the things that that we've
seen since with Trump and others, it seems
relatively milquetoast without dismissing
anyone's experience of what happened with
Al Franken.
But I had no interest.
I don't care about party.
And much like with the Andrew Cuomo thing,
it's the same thing people have been writing,
saying, David, why won't you cover the Andrew
Cuomo scandals?
I've covered every aspect of it.
I've covered the nursing home piece.
I've covered the sexual assault piece.
I've covered every single aspect of it.
And I don't care that he's a Democrat.
Let the cards fall where they may.
I am not impressed with politicians in terms
of personality, cult, of personality and define
what I don't I don't care about Andrew Cuomo.
If he did stuff wrong, then there should be
consequences.
But it is incredibly brazen to now see so
many on the right, including Don Jr. himself,
who's appearing on a nighttime right wing
media several times a week to talk about accusers
of Andrew Cuomo.
These same people, including, of course, Don
Jr., were saying nothing when Trump was accused
by a dozen women and then a second dozen.
And then what's the total number?
Forty, forty six.
Forty eight.
Fifty women or something like that.
Max Boot, who is not someone who I go to for
political analysis, actually has a pretty
good piece about this in The Washington Post
called The Andrew Cuomo Scandal Highlights
Republicans appalling double standard.
And he points out that the calls for Andrew
Cuomo to resign from people who said nothing
about the allegations against Donald Trump
or said that they were not credible and shouldn't
be believed and they should be ignored is
crazy.
And again, Max Boot points out Democrats.
Aren't giving Andrew Cuomo a free pass, The
New York Times was integral in unveiling the
sexual harassment scandal related to Andrew
Cuomo.
This is The New York Times that Trump and
other Republicans have been saying for years
is some kind of far left, a protector of all
Democrats.
And you you again see the huge double standard
is the double standard.
I've been pointing out for a long time what
Democrats were defending Anthony Weiner.
What Democrats were, if anything, the criticism
of Democrats is in order to show how they
are going to go after whoever is accused very
quickly, sometimes they go too far.
And arguably, things went too far in the early
calls for Al Franken resignation, which took
place.
Now, I know a lot of people are going to write
in and say, what about Tara Reid, the woman
who who accused Joe Biden that received a
ton of coverage and it started to fall apart
and eventually the story went away?
I don't I know that there are people who are
not going to like that characterization and
are going to say, no, no, no, it went away
because it was suppressed.
That's not what I believe took place at all.
I think it got plenty of coverage, in fact.
So I say investigate everyone, get whoever
out.
I don't care about political party.
But what we are continuing to see is exactly
the type of hypocrisy on this issue, you know,
that that we've seen from the right for a
long time.
You could you could argue it goes all the
way back to Bill Clinton.
You could argue it goes back even further
than that.
I mean, listen, we were talking about Newt
Gingrich earlier.
Newt Gingrich's past when it comes to relationships
is not exactly what the evangelical right
claims that they support or want to get behind.
So this this has decades of history behind
it.
And the hypocrisy is is stunning.
Let me know what you think.
If I'm missing something in this where I misunderstood,
I am seeing hypocrisy where there is none
or whatever.
I certainly want to hear from you.
Remember that Friday, March 26th, we are doing
a massive one day membership special we had.
I'm almost getting emotional, actually.
I just kind of choked, but it plays well.
February was a disastrous month for us.
As far as memberships go, the continued economic
pressure of the virus combined with a short
month leading to many cancelations and few
subscriptions.
So on a Friday the 26th, we are doing a massive
membership discount to try to get twenty twenty
one going for lack of a better term.
If you want to be notified about that membership
special, just get on my mailing list at David
Pakman dot com and Friday the 26th in the
morning, you will get a perfect email telling
you exactly what to do to avail yourself of
this membership discount The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.